okay so here's how not to plan a career
one and split up with boyfriend to ditch
college three go to work and struggling
record shop or become owner of said
record shop and stay there for rest of
life well there is no five she seems
better than usual is it a sweater
sweater what's wrong with me
why am I doomed to be less why am I
doomed to be rejected seriously
so I'm gonna ask my desert island
all-time top five most memorable
heartbreaks
you're really gonna talk to all of them
yeah hi Rob Oh surprised you could be a
bit obsessive
a little too in touch with your feelings
you know she told me I was obsessive and
to in touch with my feelings those are
not the words I was crazy you want to
take a Vision Quest oh into your past
and source some [ __ ] out just don't
[Music]
keep listening there might be more here
than you thought quit while you're ahead
what do you mean just stop quit before
you get to the one that broke your heart
nope I'm doing it okay sure
[Music]
you